watch it dick keep talking like that and
Bruce is gonna get the bat soap wash
your mouth out so the trailer for Titans
Wow
okay so this thing okay boy what do we
even start first time I watch this I
actually watched it with the sound off
because I I like I was I saw that it was
up and I was like in a hotel law because
this was during my vacation so I I'm
looking at this thing at movie and I'm
not listening and just looking at it
going oh boy this just I actually
tweeted this out this looks like a fan
produced trailer it would have been a
good fan produced trailer but it looks
like a fan produced trailer and so
initially I missed the thing that then
blew up social media which was the the
f-bomb dropped by Robin which is man
look I am NOT saying that you can't do
superhero stories this dark this
quote-unquote mature and the reason I do
quote-unquote is it's mature in the most
superficial way it's not true mature by
doing a deep explorative look at these
characters and what the meanings of
these sorts of sort of situations would
mean and following through to answer the
hard questions about people who live
this kind of vigilante life know it's
mature because people swear and shoot
each other I mean with that's that's um
ironically a very immature concept of
what maturity is so that's always a
weird thing to me in the first place but
again I'm not saying you can't make much
sermonizing hammock movies like this I'm
not even saying you can't even the apt
heroes like this why you would choose to
do it with heroes like this I don't get
because there are plenty of properties
out there that do naturally lend
themselves to this sort of angle I mean
it's not this severe but arrow took a
much darker take on a character who is
traditionally a bit more lighthearted
swish swish through you know a bit of
rollicking adventure swashbuckle hey hey
mild laughter Robin Hood for crying out
loud so I mean and again he's a
character who at points in the comics
has gone dark as well so when they did
arrow going dark easy care drew you can
take in that direction even though he's
not traditionally shown that way but he
still can be the core premise of Titans
is teen friends who are also heroes the
dialing up of angst and the level of
angst holy cow
and I understand teenagers have angst
but this this is the fact that it seems
to be taking yourself seriously is kind
of adorable in the same way that a high
school are completely decked out in got
gear expects to be taken seriously it's
kind of adorable so but but not for it's
not trying to be so that's I mean that's
why it fails and if it fails heart is
there a single shot in daylight I think
there might have been one with Starfire
maybe every other shot was at night like
everything like how oppressive of a
darkness are you planning to do with
this and I mean the thing is I'm not
excessively familiar with the Titans of
it generally any of every I know a
little bit even there I've seen some of
the Teen Titans cartoons I've seen some
of Teen Titans go I saw the Teen Titans
versus Justice League movie it was crap
but I also have a lot of friends who are
really big Teen Titans fans like from
back in the 80s when it kind of really
blew up significantly with the New Teen
Titans and a lot of these characters are
pulled from that that's where Beast Boy
came from that's where I'm pretty sure
Raven and Starfire originated from was
that run so I have a lot of friends who
are really into Teen Titans and one of
them his exact words were I'm really
glad they put this trailer out because
it made because I was going back and
forth on whether or not to get that DC
streaming thing now I know I'm not going
to
thanks Titans trailer so that's the
reaction from somebody who
of this stuff and speaking of somebody
who is aware of it but not really dug
that deep into it I'm again you know
what it is and it this is always the
caveat with trailers it is possible that
there is elements that I feel are
absolutely missing and would be
essential to a property like this that
are present in the show but not in the
trailer so grant that that is possible I
don't get past for that I never give a
pass
assuming that good stuff they held back
I always ago said it's possible but I
never assumed it so what this thing
needs is it needs that teenage bonding
the necessity of your friends to get you
through a tough age that's oftentimes
the core usually when it works that's
the core of the Titans
now yes you will have darkness and Hanks
Raven kind of carries that on her own
projecting that out onto every character
is completely unnecessary it's a bit
like how it felt like they tried to make
every character feel like Batman when
they did Man of Steel on Batman BBS and
it felt like they were applying the
Batman angsty nobody enjoys what they do
but they do it anyway template onto
every hero and here it feels like
they've taken Ravens you know self-doubt
darkness angst and you know potential
for destruction and stamped it onto
everybody I look at and again a lot of
it if it was a fan-made trailer I would
have thought not bad but knowing that
this is gonna be a released final
product I look at Beast Boy and go
really and hadn't the whole thing man I
just at first I was shocked in a bad way
and then I laughed for reasons I'm not
supposed to laugh what there anyone out
there who saw this trailer went yeah I
want that if that was the case for you
please tell me cuz I feel like there's
something I'm missing and at the very
least the circle people who I know
nobody gets it either so if there's
anyone out there who gets it let me know
because I don't
and those are my thoughts on the trailer
for Titans what are your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do I'm not even gonna
list it all there's a patreon link
that's the big one but links for
everything else that I do is all down in
the description if you want to check it
out so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]